TURNED WHAT THEY TOLD US WAS A
PUBLIC HEALTH RESPONSE INTO
SOMETHING THAT'S VERY MUCH LIKE
A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN.
IN A POLITICAL CAMPAIGN, THE
SIDE IS YOUR ENEMY.
SO ALL OF A SUDDEN THE PUBLIC
HAS BECOME AN OPPONENT THAT
POLITICIANS MUST SUBDUE AND
DEFEAT.
HOW DO YOU FEEL ABOUT OPPONENTS
WHO ARE WORKING FOR YOU IN
DEFEAT?
YOU FEEL LOATHING AND CONTEMPT.
THAT'S HOW THEY DO FEEL.
TAKE A LOOK AT THIS VIDEO FROM
YESTERDAY.
IT SHOWS DEMOCRATIC CONGRESS
WOMAN FROM IOWA, SHE IS
EXPLAINING HER PARTY'S RESPONSE
TO COVID.
SHE DOESN'T SAY ANYTHING THAT
REMARKABLE.
IT'S HOW SHE SAYS IT.
LISTEN TO HOW SHE TALKS ABOUT
HER CONSTITUENTS.
SHE SO CLEARLY HATES THEM.
WATCH.
>> NOW ALL THE SCHOOLS ARE BACK
WANTING TO PUT MASK MANDATES IN
AND ALL THE ANTI-VACCINE CRAZIES
ARE OUT THERE.
IT'S A HOT MESS.
CHRISTIAN RIGHT IS -- EVERYTHING
UNDER THE GUISE WHILE THEY HOLD
A CROSS, FOR GOD OR WHATEVER.
THEY USE IT LIKE A WEAPON.
IT'S PAINFUL TO WATCH BECAUSE
THEY WEAPONIZE RELIGION.
THEY WEAPONIZE POLITICS.
>> Tucker: CHRISTIANS ARE
WEAPONIZING.
NOTICE ALL THE ABORTION CLINICS
THEY CLOSED.
ALL NO IT WAS DEMOCRATIC
POLITICIANS THAT CLOSE CHURCHES,
SPEAKING OF WEAPONIZING PUBLIC
HEALTH.
BUT YOU JUST HEARD THE CONGRESS
WOMAN, THE ANTI-VAXER CRAZIES,
THE CHRISTIANS HOLDING A CROSS
FOR GOD OR WHATEVER.
IT'S HARD TO REMEMBER THOSE ARE
ACTUALLY HUMAN BEINGS SHE'S
TALKING ABOUT.
WEAKEST HUMAN BEINGS IN OUR
COUNTRY.
YOU WOULD NEVER KNOW THEY ARE
REAL PEOPLE BECAUSE SHE CLEARLY
LOATHES THEM.
SHE HATES THEM.
YOU HEAR THIS TONE A LOT FROM
POLITICIANS.
A LOT.
IT'S NOT SYMPATHY.
CERTAINLY NOT EMPATHY.
IT'S NOT EVEN A SINCERE ATTEMPT
TO MAKE PEOPLE BETTER OR
HEALTHIER.
IT'S HATE.
HERE'S THE MAYOR OF NEW YORK
THREATENING TO HURT ANYONE WHO
DOESN'T GET THE SHOT, WHETHER
THEY NEED IT OR NOT.
LISTEN.
>> MOST PEOPLE, VAST MAJORITY OF
PEOPLE, EVEN THOUGH WHO SAY THEY
DIDN'T WANT TO GET VACCINATED,
MAKE A DIFFERENT DECISION WHEN
IT BECOMES VERY VERY PRACTICAL.
NOW SOMEONE IS REALLY LOOKING AT
THE POSSIBILITY THEY WON'T HAVE
A PAY CHECK FOR A PROLONGED
PERIOD OF TIME.
THEY MAY EVEN LOSE THEIR JOB.
LOT OF PEOPLE WILL SAY, HOLD UP.
I'LL GET VACCINATED.
>> Tucker: WE'LL TAKE YOUR PAY
CHECK AWAY.
JUST PUNCH YOU IN THE FACE OR
STARVE YOU TO DEATH, BEAT UP
YOUR KIDS.
TURNS OUT IF YOU HURT PEOPLE
ENOUGH, THEY WILL DO EXACTLY
WHAT YOU SAY.
THAT ACTUALLY WORKS.
BILL DEBLASIO IS CLEARLY A
MORON, BUT EVEN HE UNDERSTANDS
THAT.
IT DOES WORK.
UNITED AIRLINES ANNOUNCED IT IS
FIRING 600 PEOPLE.
WHY ARE THEY DOING THAT?
THEY DON'T WANT TO PAY TENS OF
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS IN FINES.
NOW 600 PEOPLE ARE UNEMPLOYED.
OH BY THE WAY, THEY HAVE NO
HEALTH INSURANCE.
THAT'S HOW WE'RE MAKING MESH
HEALTHIER.
GOT IT?
THIS IS NOT JUST HAPPENING IN
THE AIRLINES.
IN HOSPITALS MASS FIRINGS ARE
NOW UNDER WAY.
WHERE'S THE CONGRESS IN THIS?
GOOD QUESTION.
MEANWHILE, ONE HOSPITAL IN NORTH
CAROLINA JUST CANNED 175 PEOPLE.
REMEMBER, THIS IS A PUBLIC
HEALTH CRISIS, RIGHT?
MAYBE WE SHOULDN'T EMPTY THE
HOSPITALS OF THE EMPLOYEES.
IT WAS ALREADY NATIONWIDE A
SEVERE SHORTAGE OF NURSES.
HOSPITALS ARE CLOSING WINGS
'CAUSE THERE'S NO ONE TO STAFF
THEM.
NOW THERE ARE FEWER PEOPLE.
NONE OF THE PEOPLE CAN COLLECT
UNEMPLOYMENT.
THEY'RE DONE.
THEY'RE DESTROYED.
THEY'RE PUNISHED.
THESE AREN'T THE CEO'S OF BIG
COMPANIES.
THESE AREN'T PEOPLE WHO LIVE IN
AFFLUENT NEIGHBORHOODS.
THESE ARE HOURLY WORKERS.
THESE ARE PEOPLE THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY USED TO CARE ABOUT.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WITH NO POWER
WHATSOEVER WHO WORK AROUND SICK
PEOPLE FOR THE DURATION OF A
DEADLY PANDEMIC.
AND RATHER THAN THANK THEM,
WE'RE FIRING THEM, WITH NO
UNEMPLOYMENT BENEFITS AND NO
HEALTH INSURANCE.
A LOT OF THEM, IN NEW YORK THE
DEADLINE FOR HEALTH CARE WORKERS
HAS ALREADY PASSED.
ACCORDING TO THE MOST RECENT
FIGURE, 16% OF THE STATE'S
HOSPITAL WORKERS, 83,000 PEOPLE,
REMAIN UNVACCINATED.
80% OF THOSE WORKERS HAVE NOT
GOTTEN A SINGLE DOSE OF THE
VACCINE.
THAT MEANS THEY'RE GOING TO BE
FIRED.
THE QUESTION IS ONCE AGAIN,
WHO'S GOING TO STAFF THE
HOSPITAL IN THE MIDDLE OF THIS
PUBLIC HEALTH CRISIS?
THAT'S AN EASY ANSWER ACCORDING
TO THE GOVERNOR OF NEW YORK.
THE STATE OF NEW YORK IS GOING
TO USE THE MILITARY TO DO IT AND
THEN HIRE TEMP WORKERS FROM THE
PHILIPPINES.
LUNACY.
BY THE WAY, ONCE AGAIN WHY
EXACTLY ARE ALL THESE HEALTH
CARE WORKERS, THOUSANDS OF THEM
NATIONWIDE, REFUSING TO GET THE
COVID VACCINE?
THAT IS AN ENTIRELY FAIR
QUESTION AND NO ONE IS ASKING
IT.
IT MIGHT BE WORTH FINDING OUT.
YOU CAN'T SAY IT'S PEOPLE WHO
DON'T UNDERSTAND THE SCIENCE.
THEY MIGHT KNOW MORE ABOUT
HEALTH CARE, CONSIDERING THAT'S
WHAT THEY DO FOR A LIVING.
THEY TREAT PEOPLE WITH COVID
EVERY DAY.
IT'S NOT LIKE THEY'RE
UNINFORMED.
WHAT IS IT, EXACTLY?
IT'S NOT A FEW PEOPLE.
IT'S THOUSANDS.
WHY?
NO ONE CARES.
PUNISH THEM.
THEY'RE WEAK.
NOW CRUSHED.
MEANWHILE, AS WE'RE FIRING
NURSES AND DOCTORS, WE'RE
LETTING THOUSANDS OF ILLEGAL
IMMIGRANTS IN THIS COUNTRY, MANY
INFECTED WITH DISEASES,
INCLUDING COVID.
YOU'RE NOT SUPPOSED TO SAY THAT
BECAUSE IT'S SOME SORT OF SLUR.
BUT IT'S FACTUALLY TRUE.
IN FACT, NOT ONLY IS IT TRUE.
SECRETARY OF HOMELAND SECURITY
JUST ADMITTED IT.
HE EXPLAINED 20% OF THE PEOPLE
COMING ACROSS THE BORDER HAVE AN
UNIDENTIFIED ILLNESS OF SOME
KIND.
HERE IT IS.
>> WE ARE CONFRONTED WITH A
POPULATION OF PEOPLE THAT, AS A
GENERAL MATTER, HAVE A RATE OF
ILLNESS OF APPROXIMATELY 20%.
>> Tucker: OH, OKAY.
SO WE'RE FIRING HEALTHCARE
WORKERS BECAUSE THEY WON'T GET
THE VACCINE AND THEN LETTING IN
THOUSANDS OF PEOPLE WHOSE
ENEMIES WE CAN'T VERIFY, WHO ARE
SICK WITH DISEASES WE CAN'T
ALWAYS IDENTIFY, INCLUDING
COVID.
NONE OF THEM ARE REQUIRED TO GET
THE VACCINE, IN CONTRAST TO THE
NURSES WE JUST FIRED.
THAT LEAVES OUR HOSPITALS SHORT
STAFFED, MANY MORE SICK PEOPLE
COMING IN WHO WILL NEED
TREATMENT AT PUBLIC EXPENSE.
WHO'S DOING THAT?
AND WHY?
WHAT IS THE POINT?
THEY'RE TELLING US THAT
HEALTHCARE WORKERS NEED TO BE
FIRED IMMEDIATELY BECAUSE THEY
ARE A THREAT TO THE COUNTRY?
THIS IS ALL HAPPENING VERY, VERY
QUICKLY.
IT'S HAPPENING WITHOUT ANY
MEDICAL BASIS WHATSOEVER.
REMEMBER, IT WAS JUST LAST YEAR
THAT JOE BIDEN WAS TELLING US
THAT HEALTH CARE WORKERS ARE
HEROES.
AND HE WAS RIGHT.
>> TO ALL THE DOCTORS AND NURSES
WHO WORK IN THE ICU UNITS, HOPE
YOU ALL KNOW YOU'RE TRULY SOME
OF THE GREATEST HEROES THIS
NATION HAS SEEN.
TAKE TRACY IN MASSACHUSETTS.
SHE'S A NURSE WHO'S BEEN
TREATING VETERANS WITH COVID-19
EVERY DAY SHE'S HAD TO PUT ON A
HAZMAT SUIT AND GO TO WORK FOR
12 HOURS DAYS ON END.
IF IT WASN'T FOR FOLKS LIKE
TRACY, OUR OWN FAMILIES WOULDN'T
HAVE A CHANCE TO BE REUNITED.
YOU WANT TO FIND A HERO IN
AMERICA, THEY'RE ALL AROUND US,
AND TRACY'S ONE OF THEM.
>> Tucker: THAT'S 100% RIGHT.
ANYONE WHO'S EVER BEEN SICK AND
HAS EVER SPENT ANY TIME IN THE
HOSPITAL KNOWS ONE GOOD NURSE
MAKES ALL THE DIFFERENCE.
THEY REALLY ARE SOME OF THE BEST
PEOPLE IN THE COUNTRY.
WHY ARE WE FIRING THOUSANDS OF
THEM?
WHY IS JOE BIDEN DOING IT?
AS A SCIENTIFIC MATTER, IT
DOESN'T MAKE ANY SENSE.
UNVACCINATED HEALTH CARE WORKERS
DO NOT POSE A THREAT TO THEIR
VACCINATED PATIENTS OR
COWORKERS, PERIOD.
IF YOU'RE VACCINATED, YOU WILL
LIKELY BE FINE.
THAT'S WHAT THE DATA SHOWS.
THAT'S WHAT THEY TELL US DAY
AFTER DAY.
VACCINATED PEOPLE HAVE A GREATER
CHANCE OF DYING FROM A LIGHTNING
STRIKE THAN DYING FROM COVID,
UNLESS THEY DIE FROM A BEE
STING, DOG ATTACK.
THOSE ARE THE NUMBERS.
WE HEAR THEM VERY OFTEN.
SO WHY ARE UNVACCINATED PEOPLE A
THREAT TO THEM?
NOT ONE PERSON HAS ANSWERED THAT
QUESTION.
NO ONE IS EVEN ASKING IT.
WHY ARE WE FIRING THEM?
WHY ARE WE BLAMING THEM?
WHY ARE WE IN THEIR FACE
ATTACKING THEM?
DEMONIZING THEM.
BUT NO ONE'S PUSHING BACK.
THIS IS COMING TO BORDER PATROL,
THE ENTIRE FEDERAL GOVERNMENT.
MASS FIRINGS ARE LIKELY TO
CONTROL IN THE BORDER PATROL
AGENCY.
IT'S CRAZY.
BUT IF THERE'S ONE SAD LESSON,
MAYBE THE SADDEST LESSON OF THIS
PANDEMIC IS THAT
AUTHORITARIANISM IS ALIVE.
LISTEN TO THE CROWD'S REACTION
AS PHIL MURPHY EQUATES NOT
GETTING THE COVID SHOT TO DRUNK
DRIVING.
>> SAYING THAT GOVERNMENTS CAN'T
MANDATE A VACCINE OR NO MASKING
IS AKIN TO SUPPORTING DRUNK
DRIVING.
IT IMPACTS THE PERSON DRIVING
DRUNK BUT ALL THE REST OF US.
THAT'S NOT THE WAY WE BEAT THIS.
>> Tucker: HOW IS IT LIKE DRUNK
DRIVING?
HOW DO UNVACCINATED PEOPLE HURT
ANYBODY?
PHIL MURPHY, GOT A SECOND?
WE'VE GOT TIME.
EXPLAIN IT TO US.
IT WAS A YEAR OR SO AGO IF A
POLITICIAN SAID THAT, THEY WOULD
BE LAUGHED OFF THE STAGE.
A POLITICIAN THAT ENDORSED
FIRING THOUSANDS OF HEALTH CARE
WORKERS DURING A PANDEMIC,
CALLING THEM CRIMINALS,
DEHUMANIZING THEM, WOULD BE
DEVILED.
NOW IT GETS APPLAUSE.
IT'S BECAUSE OUR LEADERS REALIZE
LEVERAGE FEAR TO CRUSH TPHAEUR
POLITICAL OPPONENT.
IF THAT MEANS FINING PEOPLE
$700,000 FOR EMPLOYING SOMEONE,
THROWING THE WEAKEST PEOPLE IN
OUR SOCIETY OUT ON THE STREET
WITH NO UNEMPLOYMENT I